What my wife means to say is that we
moved for move from where
married when dam it why
oh arthur stop it stop it
stop it stop it
Am I dead no why would you think that
because you are
We are an unusual couple you know oh I
don't think that was ever in question
Wanda welcome home
Vision residence
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new Wandavision
trailer video
a lot of you were asking questions about
the house of m easter eggs so i'll
explain that
why vision has the mind stone again
there's a bunch of other easter eggs in
here too for x-men stuff so we'll break
it down
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos too
we'll do a disney plus giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
easter egg from the trailer on the video
there were even some of you asking about
fantastic four act at the heartness
setup because we're going to be getting
a new version of the fantastic four in
the mcu in the next couple of years so i
will address all that stuff during this
but obviously the big stuff first the
big house of m scene because when
they're sitting there at dinner pouring
the wine
the wine bottle says meson du mapree is
french i don't speak french so i'm
probably butchering that pronunciation
but that literally translates to house
of contempt
or house of m because in french the word
mapree can also reference
mistake or not getting something right
which is obviously a reference to this
pocket reality that scarlet witch is
created
with agatha harkness there was a scarlet
witch clip of elizabeth olsen a while
ago where she was narrating a lot of her
comic book backstory where she narrates
the story of house of m
and it sounds a lot like what's going on
in this trailer so this is the clip and
think about how this applies
to the actual trailer footage scarlett's
rampage
finally ended when she was put into a
trance by doctor strange
played by none other than benedict
cumberbatch coming soon to a television
near you
the avengers and x-men decided she was
too dangerous to live and in an act of
self-preservation
in house of m scarlet witch created a
new reality where mutants
were the majority and magneto was the
ruler
but this too backfired and scarlet witch
was forced to take action
whispering the words no more mutants
so when everyone thinks of house of m
they only think about the no more mutant
situation but you have to think about
the whole theme and why
they created house of m because the
avengers and x-men decided that she was
too dangerous to live so they were going
to kill her off
it was after avengers disassembled which
is kind of what just happened in
avengers end game the avengers
effectively disassembled
until avengers 5 when they create a new
roster scarlet witch lost her mind
during that story almost wound up
killing the avengers so they decide
that's the end of it for her but in
order to save herself she creates the
pocket reality that
is house of m where mutants have
supremacy on the earth and magneto
becomes the ruler
this is when magneto is still her father
i know there's a lot of questions about
that continuity in the comics and how
they're going to incorporate that into
the mcu with the new rebooted versions
of the x-men characters
remember this is the multiverse they can
make anything canon that they want
through the multiverse
but as she says within that pocket
reality of house of m with all those
mutants things went completely off the
rails and that's what led her to the no
more mutant scenario where she got rid
of almost
all the mutants inside the house of m
reality so during the Wandavision
trailer
events just seem like they play out in a
very similar way with some twists to
sort of incorporate the continuity from
avengers end game and what's happening
after
so they end the movie vision is still
dead it seems like she just can't handle
it she's still not over his death
akka the harkness probably takes
advantage of that because it seems like
she's the antagonist of the series
during the trailer
there might be other villains behind her
i'll talk about that in a second too but
right now all we know is that she
seems like the antagonistic force that's
trying to mess with them during this
but through their actions together they
create the alternate
tv based reality that she's living in
here with vision
and slowly just like in the house of m
comic book story this reality starts to
crumble
around them like you see them glitch out
during the dinner here
then that probably leads to another big
no more mutant style
twist during the series albeit a
slightly different version of that
so during the comics it was all about no
more mutants but in this series because
people are expecting wicked and speed
the twins that she gives birth to here
to come into the main mcu reality
she could do a reverse no more mutant
style twist where she finds a way to
bring them
out of the pocket reality into the main
mcu universe
all of you have noticed that vision
still has the mind stone in his forehead
the infinity stone
is it real because thanos supposedly
atomized the mind stone that was in his
forehead before the events of avengers
end game after he snapped the infinity
gauntlet
one last time after he arrived on that
garden planet where are the stones
i used the stones to destroy the stones
so technically in the main mcu reality
after the events of avengers end game
when this series is taking place
the mind stone is still atomized so how
is it still in his forehead inside this
reality
i'm guessing that it's just a twist of
her reality warping abilities inside
here
because we see her using her reality
warping powers later in the trailer to
change the layout of her living room
that also might have something to do
with the bewitched scene that they have
earlier in the trailer when they're
still in black and white in the 1950s
looking
tv show so she talks to Vision about
fitting in with their new life here
but then when he walks in the door
looking like his android face she makes
the little emotion like samantha from
bewitched with her powers and changes
his face so that it looks like a human
face
so yes there is a lot of bewitched
easter eggs during this too but i'm
guessing because of all the different
scenes here through the different
decades of tv
they'll be referencing a bunch of
classic tv series from all different
eras of television
zoom in enhance on the newspaper here
that vision is holding a lot of you saw
this text that says little baby june and
wondered if that could be an easter egg
for june covington the dark scarlet
witch
i would not be surprised if that's the
case a lot of you are getting a legion
x-men vibe from this so if you didn't
watch the legion tv series
it was also another tv show that twisted
reality in really weird ways using the
main character's powers the legion
character's powers
scarlet witch is going to be doing the
exact same thing in this pocket reality
the tv dimension that she's living in
we get a little more information about
this pocket reality in that monica rambo
scene too because it seems like she's
getting kicked out of the pocket
dimension back into the normal
mcu universe it looks like scarlet
witch's red energy is throwing her out
so maybe she just does something to try
and break the reality of the scenario
like somehow try to get scarlet witch to
admit that this isn't all real
vision is supposed to be dead and
scarlet witch just can't handle it she
refuses to leave no he's alive i have to
stay here with him
there was a little confusion in this
monica rambo scene too in the comments
because when she gets punted through
this barrier
it looks like she's getting kicked out
of a tv screen literally
because of the red blue green tv screen
motif going on here
and when they cut to the scene of her on
the ground looking up in that 1960s or
1970s looking clothing with the big afro
you actually see another version of
monica rambo standing with the other
agents of sword in ray wise's character
here
so there was a little confusion over
whether or not there are actually two
different versions of monica rambo here
one from the alternate reality and one
from the main mcu reality
or if it's just the one version of
monica rambo and the way they cut the
trailer just makes it look like there's
two different versions of her
my assumption there is that it's just
one version of monica rambo and they
just cut the trailer in a weird way to
make it seem like there are two
different versions looking at each other
but we are talking about the multiverse
here so anything is possible there have
been a lot of crazy rumors about doctor
strange 2 multiverse of madness there
was even a rumor that there's going to
be an iron man cameo for the tom cruise
version of iron man that they almost did
in 1998
no joke before robert danny jr made iron
man in 2008
marvel was trying to make an iron man
movie back in the late 90s
with tom cruise as iron man who knows
what that would look like
i don't know if there's any truth to
that so i'm not planning on making a
video about it or anything like that but
if they confirm any big details about
other multiverse characters and cameos
popping up especially during Wandavision of course i'll add it to my
videos
it's not totally clear why they're going
with the tv motif of this alternate
reality like maybe she's somehow
watching tv
watching some sitcoms watching people's
lives play out and she thinks about the
life that she wanted for herself
and how she can't have that because
vision is dead how would they have
children because he's an
android would that even be possible but
through her actions in agatha harkness's
actions who's also a very powerful
sorceress in her own right they find a
way to create this pocket reality where
scarlet witch can use her reality
warping abilities to make all those
things come true
create the life for herself that she
always wanted to have that's where you
bring it all back around to the whole
house of m
idea creating a pocket dimension a
pocket reality where she can do whatever
she wants
as for agatha harkness fantastic four
connections i think anything is possible
they're just laying the seeds for a lot
of early setup in marvel phase four here
and this is just the beginning
so i think they're just trying to create
more of the sword story after spider-man
far from home with the sword agency and
nick fury that's where monica rambo
comes in
i'm assuming if they're going to give
her her powers like she has in the
comics because she was a version of
captain marvel at one point in marvel
comics
they'll wait for the captain marvel
sequel movie to do that
but i think in terms of connecting this
to other big mcu movies i think this is
more connected to doctor strange too if
we're talking about agatha harkness
because she's a magic user
doctor strange keeps a short list of all
the most dangerous magic users on the
planet agatha harkness would probably be
on that list
like the license plate easter egg says
102 that's for avengers 102 a story
where vision gets offered wonder man's
body in exchange for turning on the
avengers
this time it might just be agatha
harkness that's preying on scarlet witch
trying to tease her with the idea that
she can bring
vision back to life albeit through this
really twisty
alternate reality way in scarlet witch
we'll go directly from the end of Wandavision
into doctor strange too as a big
crossover character but if they drop any
more trailers before then or we get any
more information about that of course
i'll do videos
so leave all your requests in the
comments below if you have any big
questions about what's going on with
Wandavision or the other series
congratulations velathor you're the
giveaway winner for my last big marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so i can get your contact
details
everyone click here for my other Wandavision trailer video in easter eggs
and click here for that new chris
hemsworth avengers 5 thor 4 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!